welcome to scream junkies or should I
say scream junkies guys we're talking
about some of the most terrifying movies
of all time today let's get ready to get
spooky
first off he is a very funny and spooky
writer he's the writer of Seinfeld the
purge John Ford high E is a
spine-tingling gentleman who hosts one
of the best movie review shows around
Chris stuckman and this man is a monster
a mad monster he's the head monster at
mad monster magazine welcome back
evan magar we're talking scary movie
moments today what are the elements that
make a scary movie moment yummy more so
than the jump scare is the sense of
dread the feeling that you're you know
in the roller coaster you can't get off
you know for me that was the Exorcist
you know when Marin and Cara's have to
go into the room with Regan and you just
don't know what you're gonna get that's
such a classic moment
father if this said I'll throw it out
there the hand reaching out of the burnt
rubble from Carrie OH at the end that's
one of the like original like jump scare
moments at hand coming out of the grave
Evan clown from poltergeist fought that
clown so we had a few of the big ones
there now let's talk about ones that we
individually really love that stand out
gremlins is one of the first horror
movies I remember like seen in theaters
specifically the scene they come in you
hear the Christmas music and that seemed
like takes all these things you have
these really warm associations with like
choose them and throws them into this
nightmare about your mom getting
murdered
gremlins ruined Christmas or made it
better now okay yeah goodness it's like
Halloween - Chris one of the things that
really surprises me in movies is when a
film is able to take something that you
normally view a certain way and show you
it in a different way and for instance
the film's signs really did that for me
when I was younger
first time you see the alien in science
is on a handheld shaky cam Brazilian
video with
kids screaming and then Joaquin Phoenix
is watching that in the television so
you are in the role of your average
person at home who's experiencing an
alien invasion
I actually had my legs like up in the
seat and I was hugging them and I've
never forgotten that scene ever to this
day
Evan is there another one that uh really
grabs you when it first came out
Zelda from Pet Sematary got me the the
sister with the twisted back never get
out again and then a different kind of
terror for me awakenings
the idea of you know Robert De Niro
knowing he's shutting down it has that
like Johnny got his gun moment where
like you know you're there but you're
trapped inside your body I was watching
him shut down to me that was pretty
terrifying yeah there's something just
like so psychologically troubling about
that like put my tomatoes in my closet
over that any day let's keep going what
are some other movie moments that haunt
you one that was really unexpected was a
movie where I was sitting it as a kid
thinking Harrison Ford is so awesome I
want to be Indiana Jones and then all of
a sudden someone's getting their heart
ripped out of their chest
what the hell happened John you've
another one that uh grabs you but I
remember like being like maybe 12 and
watching Videodrome James Woods it's
just these like mysterious videotapes it
was this weird like mirror moment or
it's like I rented this weird scary
videotape and now I'm watching like
James Woods watch these like weird scary
videotapes I'll throw one out there that
really just grabbed me as a kid from
something you would never expect um tell
them Large Marge Sencha from pee-wee's
big adventure he was a big adventure one
of my all-time faves yeah um and it's
delightful
except for that moment that is
horrifying and when they finally pulled
the drivers body from the twisted
burning wreck it looked like this lots
of those things people remember uh
bigger and scarier than they were like
the opening and while I don't want my
favorite horror film opening yes sure
you don't want to see something really
scary scare me yeah dan Aykroyd
werewolves yeah just out of me another
one that hit me from out of nowhere
unexpected mohon drive when the homeless
guy behind the dumpster behind the diner
just it's startling
speaking of domestic horror films from
an older time period wait until dark
with Audrey Hepburn came out in 1967 I
believe and Alan Arkin plays a killer in
that movie Audrey Hepburn's blind
throughout the entire movie and there's
a great shot at the end where she starts
to realize someone's in her house she
busts all the lights out and Alan Arkin
now can't see and then he just burst out
from behind the wall with this knife and
gets her across the healed to me it's
one of the scariest movie moments of the
60s what is your recommendation for the
scary movie to watch with the most sense
of dread he's gone the evil has gone
from him he's gone he's gone from it the
evil is gone Halloween I mean you cannot
go wrong with that and one of the scenes
that creeps me out every time is this
really long take of Jamie Lee Curtis
walking down the sidewalk and you just
see Michael his shoulders come into
frame and you hear that I would be
terrified if I saw that on the street
you know it brought it home or even just
a hey freak speed kills hey jerk speed
kills take a joke this should be a
cautionary tale of you don't know you
talked to do shut up
John are you gonna watch anything
particular to uh yourself scare man I
might recommend a film currently in
theaters oh yeah I just I saw the gasps
it's a weird like it's a hybrid of like
John of like Halloween like the Bourne
movies right drive and it's just like
it's we're definitely were themed really
nice we've hit old we've hit new we hit
everything in between hey what's your
scariest movie moment the one that
haunts you when you close your eyes at
night and it's still in your head
let us know in the comments section
below the best answer we're gonna send
you a spooky screen junkies t-shirt and
I want to thank my gruesomely
spooktacular panel John Ford Chris
stuckman Evan magar thanks for being
here fellas and thank you for watching
the show I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye do you have any idea
what we can expect in Justice League
part 1 I'm assuming they're going to
build the dark side
if Marvel is going to push Pano's off to
the side for a while that would make the
most sense to seize that opportunity to
have to pick Darth Vader